hello my name from Vasiliev's sharaf of the
taiga I'm trampling it on the fault of a shred of a needle to the
headquarters
[music]
every morning leaving the house
you get confused not to get confused and not
get lost because you are trying to find a
new car
because
probably 10 cars I have already been looking for
here in the yard
they give me cars  I pass on there
were minibuses of three types
, there were some kind of Mars of Odessa,
maybe it
was given by the
forest
[music]
on the 23rd or I clearly understood that the
war would start on 2 4 for this I needed to
watch a little bit of youtube check
and short videos in youtube checks showed
I
didn’t sleep completely at night and completely everything here
I heard how the plane passed over my house
heard the first explosions and
quietly began to be my loved ones by
phone calls
raised her saying something in a
phrase that I don’t know I
never said everything before  just passe don't
worry the war started
[music]
sorry friends
0 I will make pizzas
lovely I arrive on time strongly if
not by means of for sure I was late again
we will not notice always on time comes
here on time
threw a day to this headquarters look
at them in the pictures our stove in other
pictures carp plate 2 degrees of protection
which came in the
third her choice to whom  you understand that
we’ll look at the second one look at the group at the
headquarters, I would like to raise the question of where the
military registration and enlistment office and give the bulletproof vest so that it doesn’t
happen so that the ATM gave it to the
same part where they are and look at mine at the
moment they shipped the central end yesterday
I added 40 pieces to the regional military registration and enlistment office
before that, we shipped 50 pieces to the
city military registration and enlistment office in Odessa,
look today, 5
machines promised 1a should arrive by new mail, I see
that it is going and 4 promised to bring it and people
physically well, I promise that the fabric is already
on a sewing machine about that, new ones, moreover,
after spending Sasha, Ben’s
clothes  and a warehouse maximum for humanitarian
medical assistance and displacement Ksyusha
head  headquarters here in the Khakassia Sasha
Dima’s construction is the coordination center and
hotline of Bogdan’s potbelly stove Lera
making cocktails near her kitchen
Sonia transport novel is that we see that
whether the wife is lying long by the sergeants and
or is formatted resting in
minibuses and buses and cars go
to their troops built Biron Henry
[  music]
leads by weights drank aroma immersing
effective times in weight
here on the territory two divisions
one medical medical
vibrator 2 from Monday the
sewing workshop will start here we were handed over the
machines we are bringing to mind we are raising from the
ruins and we will launch here another
shift helmet vobla cough  carlos children
are the workshops that my friend gene rents the
production of children's swings in the hill
some cool barbecues in the second furniture the
mind put all this soul into it made the coolest
loft-style office a person just with such a
detailed about his such nature a
German to do everything to the maximum does not do
half on  for window cool conditions well and
so got  there is a
sewing shop there is a welding shop there is a
reception room that became our headquarters there is a
kitchen that became our micro kitchen
later on this shop is located on a
large territory of the
former repair complex of AvtoVAZ and
there are many warehouses of boxes for
repairs of warehouse and office premises and
what  -that moment the owners of these
premises came and told
you the keys you can do some things experience my
friend was
looking for his cousin and
through our military connections I managed to
find her this brother found mine in the morgue
and
thanks to the tattoo I need him now he
came to the rotation the fighter is not on the rotation
came on a business trip here for the funeral of a
cousin, they let him go, we will
now give him to part 2 of a
bulletproof vest
abroad, they said they did
n’t understand the money a little and much turnout,
then the application is necessary, they said for and until there is
necessarily a ricochet distance,
it seems unlikely that
experimental firing and two new ones will arrive
saw blade boards  how not to give free
rein to the
disk sawmills for granite set
fire
[music]
it withstood a
good result dad steel we went out
rub the class sure I would like 4 but
one for now 3 in any case we will chop
those saws that we have and but put it aside
for the moment when  we will run out of
Swedish steel and there won’t be Finnish yet,
so what will we do
I have a small event company
that organizes
holidays and parties of
some kind and lance to be an event
company that brings
joy and fun and I worked in it as
leaders and presenter who spent
everything  these mass cultural events and it
so happened that a huge number of
my clients who did not get scared came to
me and stood where the terme lived, and on the shoulder
, someone sent money in
envelopes or on a card someone
came to help you with their hands
[music]
this  600d
600 density 40 meters 40 meters 102
in the
workshop, necks that have healed as an assistant, she
cuts all kinds of fabrics and
each one comes in order that
at the moment we have carried out 11 tons of steep
steel, but we understand that we need
about 100 tons,
we still don’t have that kind of money to buy
100 tons, and therefore, as soon as it ends
and  We will use volume 311, but what
we used earlier
at the moment, and from steel about top 500,
it will make one thousand one hundred pairs of plates,
most of them more than 800, we
put in those bulletproof vests that are those in
plate carriers of the people about the places that we
ourselves went to here in production
[  music]
but a
hundred
[music]
you’ll give us six and a
half tons from Zhytomyr he’s milk now we have
cheese soup
coming that and the organizational meeting on
average everything is fine
[music] the
salary will not be
until who is stable we made her
day off for the first time because we understand
no one will plant potatoes here without us notes of
those people who need bulletproof vests
in order to hand them over to the armies now
we will get it and where we promised on Friday
Saturday from here 5 pieces of paper and we will single out
those very bulletproof vests if you don’t rejoice
and laugh even terribly the situation is very
important quickly with sour do not screw
your head with ashes and
allow yourself
to be happy
look at the glades
and
all these people are in the usual  of life,
large managers of different directions, the
guitar of insurance companies, construction
companies, financial directors, there is not
a single official here, there is not a single
person who applies papers
or pretends to work and
a cool backbone of 12 and 14
people of the headquarters was formed who closed the main
directions and began to do everything on these
places are very us and so worn firstly
acts to do secondly to surround yourself with
people who act to make the clinic
dreams and third to everything even the most
terrible treat with feeling
[music]